ciudades enteras hundidas bajo el agua y
gente abandonando sus casas son las
imágenes que han dejado semanas de
fuertes lluvias en el estado de bahía en
brasil aportaba locura hay un puente ahí
es una locura es como el mar hubo una
ola de casi dos metros de altura estamos
tristes pensando en nuestras familias
nuestros compromisos nuestras deudas
pero no se puede bromear con dios verdad
es muy triste ver nuestra ciudad así
extremadamente triste no había visto
nada igual en mi vida con miles de
damnificados los equipos de rescate se
desplegaron en las ciudades afectadas
para brindar asistencia mientras que
otros miles ya han sido evacuados ante
el peligro de desbordamiento de los ríos
en los próximos días la expectativa es
de mejoría pero aún así el gobierno
sigue recomendando precaución
quiero pedirles a las personas que se
encuentran en los municipios más
afectados donde el nivel de agua está
subiendo que abandone sus hogares y
busquen lugares seguros hoy todavía
estoy en ilhéus trabajando y
monitoreando las acciones de nuestro
grupo de trabajo a raíz de los hechos el
presidente del país jair bolsonaro
sobrevoló la zona para comprobar el
alcance de los daños y se espera que el
gobierno central ponga en marcha un
programa de operación y ayuda a los
damnificados que de momento recibirán
cerca de 230 euros las lluvias desde
diciembre han sido seis veces superiores
a la media algo que los expertos
relacionan con la crisis climática
mundial